soon all shops and restaurants across
Europe's biggest economy will be able to
reopen with social distancing in place
for many weeks the government's been
trying to chart a course through the
corona virus pandemic one which would
cause the fewest deaths and protect the
economy compared to the UK Italy Spain
and France Germany has undoubtedly had a
better result
now ministers believe the virus is under
control and so can ease the many
restrictions we will not install
contacts the way they were before if
everyone observes the distancing and
hygiene rules then there is a good
chance that it will remain this way
otherwise we wouldn't have made these
decisions I said we are following a bold
path and we believe that with the
present framework conditions we have a
chance however I want to repeat that we
are even more reliant on people
cooperating underlying this decision is
the clear fear among the political elite
about the damage coronavirus has already
caused this economy and what it might go
on to do which explains why they're so
keen to relax restrictions wherever
possible but as they are relaxed so the
responsibility for monitoring the
progression of coronavirus will devolve
to the 16 states of Germany anywhere
with more than 50 people infected for
every 100,000 residents must reinstate
lockdowns one part of German life that
will resume shortly is the Football
League Bundesliga officials have been
told they can allow games to be played
but with no fans in the stadiums and
following stringent rules and testing
regimes one sector where uncertainty
remains is aviation the national flag
carrier Lufthansa has been badly hit by
the grounding of so many flights and
says it needs urgent government help to
stay airborne search via if you have
never alistair we have difficult times
ahead of us but we will do everything in
our power to reach the goals we have set
ourselves those goals are the survival
of Lufthansa and we start in the company
some cultural activities have already
restarted as here at the Barberini
Museum in Potsdam a welcome move
visitors who felt culturally stifled
these past months reopening one Museum
is one thing restarting an entire
economy quite another because all the
while hundreds of new infections are
still occurring every day
Dominic Kane al-jazeera Berlin